first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings today
I'm joined by Tinashe the first female
guest and how was history
what's the vibe going into this one how
you feeling actually extremely nervous
and I don't even get nervous but one I
don't like hot wings - I don't eat spicy
food three this says pain 100% so the
kid does death
so I mean well if this is it for us
you should know that joy ride comes out
early 2016
yep the single-payer I liked it before
saw the Fallon performance no I love it
thank you thank you I think big things I
think it's fair yeah so if I don't make
it through by it right on iTunes ready
this yep
all right so the first one is just
sriracha basically ketchup nothing to
worry about
you ready like actually like a good
delicious dim plans to move out of the
house or is it gonna be you and the
parents for the foreseeable future
I have loose plans when we were out of
the house within the next like I don't
know 16 to 18 months we'll see what
happens here's a couple things though
they like would hang me up like first
off when I go home like my dad doesn't
know the Wi-Fi password he got into DVR
like two years ago I was like I could
never ever live with you these days yeah
what about uh if he asks like your dad
asks you to vacuum the living room is
there ever part of you that's like I've
got a platinum plaque on the wall like
I'll get to it when I get tight luckily
my parents never ask me to vacuum the
living room shout out to the parents you
know maybe new Shores but um if they did
I mean my living rooms like five feet by
five feet so it'd probably take me like
ten minutes
I could do it what if you want to smoke
or something you have to hide it like a
high school sophomore I go on my car
season to new hot sauces Tapatio a new
one would you think of that one not bad
my bad I can hand I can hang speaking of
your car mm-hmm the album was called
Joyride and I've heard you say that you
know you've written songs in the car
that you feel inspired in the car yep
the aux cord though that's kind of a
sacred thing it really is do you control
the aux cord or do you hand it off to
all shine first of all there's rarely a
guest passenger in my car I'm a solo
dolo writer I don't need a passenger to
complete me I can listen to the music by
myself right around getting my five
actually that's one of the reasons why I
really enjoy being in the car is because
it is like kind of like my long time my
personal space
so I definitely control the aux cord at
all times number three this is a Yucatec
Oh classic Mexican again not all that
bad okay so the last album was called
Aquarius are you one of those people
that's like really into horoscopes and
stuff
I mean I'm more
like my own personal sign than all the
cities in general I'm not a super like
for Sophie person but sometimes I like
to take like a little tidbit here and
there of a horse welcome for ten like
I'm into it the thing that bothers me
about horoscopes they're kind of
wishy-washy but let me read you your
horoscope for the day and you tell me if
it rings true okay it would be tempting
to surround yourself with yes people so
many one who agree with you right now of
course your true friends are the ones
will support you when you're right and
tell you when you're wrong I feel like
that's very accurate it is but that's
like a piece of advice to tell anybody
in the music industry right like we're
so surrounded by people who are like as
dope it's awesome is so good you have to
have people are upset you trust how
about whoever on your team put you on
this show to eat dangerously hot wings I
don't trust them anymore at all I'm an
artiste sweating in the face we've only
got two wing three
already doing laps around DJ Khaled
though this next one another new one hi
River hellacious hot sauce whoo okay
hellacious let me do it one two three go
so given that you've been in the
entertainment industry since we're
basically five years old
uh-huh a lot of kids when they're
growing up they're asked you know like
what do you want to be when you grow up
and people say like I want to be a
singer I want to be in movies I want to
be on the TV you know I want to be on TV
but you had those dreams realized at an
early age so I wonder do you ever
fantasize though about having some
normal civilian job and if you do what
would it really want to work at rite-aid
I don't but if I were to have a normal
civilian job it would probably be like a
french fry connoisseur I'm good at fries
not so much at hot wings I don't know if
a fry connoisseurs job it is totally
okay sure
five is paint as good louisiana-style it
is good Pena's meet this guy on the
cover looks like he's in so much pain
mean everybody who's been on the show I
think has referenced this kid screaming
on the cover it looks like he is
suffering so much it's a mixed message
though it's actually like pain is good
though you know what I mean like he's in
pain but oh files and tribulations as my
friend DJ Khaled told me on the show
marking tribulation so this next
question he's inspired by the player
video mm-hmm because what you do is you
basically go head-to-head in these dance
battles throughout and then you wash all
these dancers under the table but then
you come face-to-face with breezy breezy
and it's like you've met your match you
know what I'm saying what I want to do
is I want to show you three celebratory
dances from this football season
touchdown dances and then you break them
down and you tell me if you'd wash them
or if they'd give you a run for your
money does that good yep laptop please
this first one is Cam Newton and he's
gonna dab on him oh okay I think I know
this Dan he's getting ready oh okay
he's feeling it oh oh we have a little
it will start to it okay I think my
favorite part of him is that he dabs so
hard that he makes the other team mad
and they confront him like they're gonna
fight him and then he just keeps dabbing
on him when they get mad he's like yep
hmm I did all right yeah no I can take
him I challenge you Cam Newton to a
dance battle this next one's Odell
Beckham jr. okay what does this dance
called oh I think he's just goofing but
it's kind of cool
oh okay the whip king that was
interesting but I could challenge him
man showed me some real competition all
right this last one arguably the best
okay
it's a Ravens kicker Justin Tucker
mm-hmm some would say he's doing a
little too much I think he's doing yeah
not even no nothing not okay that was a
nice little dance that was a nice little
move I could add that to my legs five
six seven eight my little repertoire I
can challenge all of them all of them
all of them no match for tonight dance
battle what hi River rogue number six
I'm trying to find like the we saucy
spot five I like bucket hot ones it's a
chess game that one's actually like kind
of how my fingers take a sip oh my god
yeah we just stepped it up like ten
levels that's what happens on hot ones
it's kind of like you please for a while
and then you get it okay how do you know
when you're two on like for me things
start to like get a little bit loose on
my fourth drink [ __ ] is really not
called wild ones
Josie I'm sweating Wow do you know when
you're two on how do you know when
you're two on I know that I am two on
because I start like texting my eggs
like some [ __ ] that I don't even
remember
that's classic John behavior what
happened
yeah that's fully two on got like three
on to be honest - honest like you're
still enjoying yourself three honest
like you've lost all control
alright now this next one and I still
burn so I really gotta go to the next
more about 60 100% right
so now this one is I'm being dead
serious about it I'm nervous on this one
I don't like this one I don't know how
big your bites are but I would cut
whatever bite you're taking in half okay
it doesn't even taste like food it
tastes like there's our pain a hundred
percent
it tastes like uh like metal where hey
how are you talking
you ever see Michael Jordan dunk and
you're like how does he do that
but it's he's just touched by the hand
of God same alright you have a black
belt mm-hmm
if they did a Ghostbusters remake but
instead with three ninjas who would you
want to be flanked on your side I mean I
feel like I definitely mean need at
least one dude till I kick someone's ass
I'm gonna go Christian Bale Chris okay
maybe Batman okay all right
it's pretty good I was thinking like
machinist Christian Bale so I was like
what the hell I was thinking back I was
thinking Batman looks good at Batman
Batman Begins sounds like you just want
Batman no all right yes okay Batman
Batman back
I picked Batman I got on the other side
Missy Elliott good one
you could tolerate pain a hundred
percent what was your karate teacher
like to meet you guys mr. shin
cuz that's to me true kind is he like a
wise sensei type or like a dude that
just watched a lot of jean-claude Van
Damme movies and no one would mr. shin
roundhouse you taught me how to speak in
Korean though I'm not bull that may sue
just uh you got yeah oh yeah this one is
a bomb it is the bomb twenty four times
hotter than a jalapeno and insanity
beyond insanity so we used to have
insanity hot sauce but looks like we
stuffed it up this is beyond thank you
what do you think was the best song of
2015
like what's the best get down to it song
2015
I didn't have that much sex in 2015 huh
not the first person out
I was really pissy I was but you know my
music and you know what work okay I
would say is it the weekend is it yeah
we know it's cool but this album wasn't
very like what's I feel like we're more
like Bryson tiller like maybe a little
dumb I'm alive Bryson tiller don't I
think that's a good engine for song
right hot right yeah I'm really hot up
how you doing
I'm Haines I'm gonna win I'm gonna make
it through you are cuz you can't stop
now handsome now number nine is Mad Dog
357 now in season 1 this was the hottest
hot sauce that'll make you hard so
please now we have death sauce to top it
off and I don't need to I don't mean to
gas you up so much but you're doing a
lot better than I thought you would like
wouldn't work I didn't know better than
I thought I when they were doing
lighting and sound and you were telling
me all that was going through your head
before this I was like oh she's gonna DJ
Cal I've had at one one wing but she is
repping for the ladies I'm negative see
I'm not gonna lose especially to you
Jesus
well I'm not gonna lose either it's
gonna be a stalemate Mad Dog oops I
think you're all hyped up on that ninja
question so
between a Katy Perry and Nicki Minaj mmm
who has the better Tour rider we put
some obscure things on the rider to like
see if anyone actually gets it for us
you know that's the move likes him just
like random stuff like socks like who's
gonna put give us actual socks can you
came through what is like what clerk
what sorts of things around there
scented candles Plain White T's chips
and salsa what's on yours
chips and salsa we're really going
through it alright last question
yeah it's tradition to dab the last wing
come on if you want to if you want to
not I understand I got to do it
Megadeth it's not this isn't fun with
liquid rage perfect just what I'm so hot
ones fans this is a new number 10 it's
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
thank you for the liquid rage add a
little bit of that right there
OOP oh I got two drops of liquid raise
you're perfect now they say it's 500
times hotter than a jalapeno if we did
we did the math on the scovilles it
actually is more like a hundred and ten
times hotter than a jalapeno not that it
really matters once you get to that love
Austin just so I have a puke wagon you
guys my god it's so sad scum Zimbabwe he
is and I got to do it for Zim
is it true that you can speak Shona no
that's fully alive I can sing like some
songs and some and Shona but I can't
speak Shum it's hard alright
you can sing some songs or Sean yeah
that's pretty amazing hmm so could you
maybe just we'll take a bite of this
last one and then maybe you could sing
us a song and Seana to send it off
sure
we do armed and applause you know
buzzing all dancing star way mm-hm
you know some days you know and we got a
deer I did it I made it throughout the
week
Tinashe such a like I wouldn't believe
I'm going up core under under dirt rated
underrated put Tinashe his name in the
rafters and since he got it all the way
through the floor is yours
plug away let the people know why they
need to cop joyride I mean my face is
fully sweating but you should definitely
get a new album joyride it's available
as soon as you want it to be on iTunes
so should go get it download it go to my
website to notch it out calm down with
all my mixtapes my old album Aquarius
and just live love life you know check
out that all-hands-on-deck video yes I
love it
yeah you got the dance moves and
everything were you a little impressed
by that
I was impressive
careless [ __ ]
nice meeting you chilly o'clock that
meet you
you're on I think is like that girl
everybody horner and she might give too
much blue you'll shake it sometimes you
got to take fall to win bigger have I
experienced roadblocks